That's not just any stunt cameraman.
That's Sam Hargrave, the director
of Netflix's action movie "Extraction."
To create this one shot
required a complicated maneuver.
First he unstrapped himself
from the hood of a car,
then he ran over to
another car to film inside,
and then he had to repeat the same shot
from two different positions precisely
to allow for a seamless final edit.
The result was this: a
shot that goes smoothly
from outside a fast-moving
vehicle to inside the car
without any visible interruption.
And that's just three seconds
of a 12-minute-long sequence
filmed to look like a single shot,
which required camera moves
by foot and by harness,
complex stunts, invisible cuts,
and a cast that could endure
extended fight scenes.
The director wanted the audience
to see the complicated act
of mercenary Tyler Rake
extracting the kidnapped
Ovi happen in real time
and felt that one long
take was the way to do it.
The entire sequence
consists of a car chase,
then a chase up some stairs,
a fight in a building,
a jump from one rooftop to another,
a tumble off an awning,
a fight in the street,
and one final car chase,
which amounts to about
36 different segments attached together,
creating an impressive 12-minute,
seemingly continuous scene.
From planning to shooting,
it took approximately
four to five months to bring
this one sequence to life.
First they looked at large maps
of the location in India
and highlighted routes
where they would be shooting the scene.
Then they choreographed the chase shots
using toy cars, labeling
each one carefully.
Sam Hargrave: One of the
logistics, 'cause it's not just
me and a camera and, you know,
Chris Hemsworth in a car.
There's hundreds of people involved
in making this happen, so
where do you stage them?
It was a really intense,
technical puzzle to solve.
Narrator: Hargrave is no stranger
to big, one-take action scenes.
On top of being a stuntman and coordinator
for multiple Marvel movies,
he famously choreographed
the memorable 10-minute,
one-take fight scene
in "Atomic Blonde."
While most movies might require
one or two location scouts,
this movie required seven to eight.
During scouting, the crew needed to find
the most narrow and
claustrophobic streets possible
as well as buildings
that provided passageways
for easy, continuous shooting.
Sometimes they would alter the
location to fit the sequence,
and other times the location would alter
what the script looked like.
For example, while this one building
offered the perfect
balcony for Chris Hemsworth
and Randeep Hooda to start fighting,
it did not have an awning
that allowed their characters
to tumble off the building,
so the crew constructed one.
Before actually shooting the scene,
all of the stunts were rehearsed
and filmed on location.
Hargrave: We were testing
and proving everything
so that when we got there,
there were no unanswered questions.
We knew exactly where
stitches were gonna happen,
how were we going to, you know,
throw this person over a
balcony and capture that.
Narrator: The sequence
beings with a car chase.
This is when Hargrave strapped himself
to the hood of a vehicle.
The small vehicle allowed him
to squeeze through some tight
spaces, like this tunnel.
Most movies film car
chases using a pursuit arm,
which is a camera mounted
to a vehicle meant to follow action.
You can see one used
during the chase scenes
though the streets of
Busan in "Black Panther."
So, why do this instead?
Stylistically, it allowed them to switch
more seamlessly to a handheld
style when they needed to.
Practically, it allowed for mobility
for shots where the camera
switches perspective
from outside Tyler Rake's car to inside.
Hargrave's vehicle had to pull up
directly alongside Rake's car,
then Hargrave unclipped himself
and put the camera as far
inside the car as possible.
Then, once he could get inside the car,
he leaned out the window
and then pulled the camera
back in to reshoot the same action
and the same background.
This allowed the two shots
to be stitched together.
Hargrave said that he had
to replicate it precisely,
and if he was off by even a few degrees,
they would have to
shoot it all over again.
Eventually, they have to
get the two main characters
out of the car and onto the street.
In order to get the
camera to leave the car
without a cut, the
window needed to shatter
during this crash.
The camera was hard-mounted inside the car
and then put onto a slide,
where it could then be pushed
through the now empty window space
so Hargrave could grab
it and continue the shot
up a flight of stairs as
he chased a group of cops
and then eventually met back up
with the two main characters.
That's where things got complicated.
Because the hallways were only about
three and a half feet wide,
he had to avoid stepping
over fallen bodies
or running directly into the fight.
And when you see the camera back up
and eventually follow Ovi away,
Hargrave had to count
the exact number of steps
he was walking backwards so
he wouldn't crash into a wall.
Hargrave: To get that
right, I think we had to do,
I think it was 21 takes.
Narrator: And because
the crew was so mobile,
they had to rely on natural light
as much as possible to light scenes.
Lighting kits were only
used when necessary,
like inside cars and inside the truck.
While this was all one
long, continuous take,
they still needed to call
"Cut!" at some point.
So the sequence is full
of invisible stitches,
like when the window was shattered.
Hargrave: Sometimes, the
places, the locations,
weren't right next to each other
and they weren't sequentially,
you weren't able to shoot
and move through them sequentially.
Narrator: When Ovi ducks into a room
and starts throwing objects,
that doorframe was used as a stitch point.
In reality, they recreated the room
in another building down the street.
Hargrave: It was, like,
you know, 10 blocks away
because the room had more access,
had more space to shoot.
Narrator: If not done correctly,
this can create a continuity nightmare.
So to successfully cobble
these shots together,
they had to recreate the first doorframe
in the second location,
so they looked exactly
the same in both places.
Hargrave: That actual
location where he comes out
is another place where we had to stitch,
and that was just a couple
doors down from that location
'cause what we're trying to, you know,
get the person to believe
is he goes in that door,
goes down the room,
and comes out, you know, not far away
where Chris still was.
Narrator: Stitches were also necessary
for some of the more dangerous stunts.
When Tyler jumps from one roof to another,
they had to switch from
Hemsworth to his stunt double.
So they put in a stitch right here,
as the shot switches to the
back of the character's head,
allowing Hemsworth to
swap out with his double.
Stunt doubles came in again when Hemsworth
and Hooda's characters
tumble off a balcony
and into the street.
Director: Three, two, one, go!
Narrator: Here's Hemsworth
watching as his double,
Bobby Holland Hanton, took the fall.
This was one of the
hardest shots to capture
and was as much a stunt for Hargrave
as it was for the actors.
Hargrave said that,
normally, a shot like this
might have anywhere from
four to five cameras.
Hargrave: Whatever they'd give
me, as many as they could,
so that you could, if something goes wrong
or if the pacing's off,
you could cut around it.
Narrator: With just one camera...
Hargrave: Because I
wanted to be close to them
to feel the impact of the fall
but also wide enough to see the fall.
Narrator: So to get the shot,
Hargrave jumped off the balcony
and over the awning with them,
roped into a pulley system.
It allowed him to hop right
behind them as they fell
and then got on the ground right on time.
After five tries, they got it right.
Then the two actors
continued to duke it out
in the middle of the street.
Because there are no visible cuts
and the camera had to
keep rolling and rolling,
the fight scenes were especially
challenging for the actors.
Because they couldn't
cut to different angles,
there was no way for them to fake it.
The actors would also
have to be ready to move
as a small vehicle goes right
between them during the fight,
a detail they incorporated
after location scouting.
In the final stretch of the sequence,
Tyler and Ovi steal a truck
for one last big chase.
They actually did use a special vehicle
with a pursuit arm for this part.
This was the only way they
could physically keep up
with the one-unbroken-take illusion.
Hargrave: We had a camera
vehicle so that we could
race up beside the truck
and get into the car
deeper than I could.
When I was safety-ed in,
my arms only go so far.
But we could get this action vehicle
in a little deeper to the car.
Narrator: CGI came in handy for the moment
where Tyler and Ovi jump out of the truck.
According to Hargrave,
the jump was originally just hinted at.
However, in the editing room,
they decided they wanted
to actually show it,
but this location was no longer available.
So first they had to rebuild the street
and tunnel on an airport
tarmac in Thailand.
There, they had the
stunt doubles leap out.
After that, they worked backwards
by having the two actual
actors recreate the moment
before the characters
jumped out of the truck
in front of a green screen.
So this shot of them about
to leap out of the truck
and them actually falling out
is two different shots in two
completely different locations
connected seamlessly.
When the truck flips over,
the continuous take ends.
While it was important to
keep the momentum going
and always have something
exciting happening on screen,
Hargrave also found the best way
to keep the audience engaged throughout
was by pulling back.
In the moments before Tyler
and Ovi jump off the roof,
there was supposed to be
a huge fight on the roof,
but Hargrave decided to scrap it.
Hargrave: There's been
so much action before,
and there's about to be so much more.
And we can't make this
decision in the editing room.
We can't just, you know, cut around
and say, "Well, let's speed this up."
We said, "I think right
now we're overloading
the audience with action.
We need to take a break,
we need to, like, insert
a little joke here."
Narrator: So they settled with this
unscripted moment of comic relief.
Tyler: All right, kid, you trust me?
Ovi: No.
Tyler: Good.
Ovi: No!